- OH!
- WHAT?
- OH, MY GOSH!
- WHAT A HALF!
- THAT IS CRAZY!
- OH, MY GOD.
- OH, MY GOSH.
- HEY, UH...
FORGOT TO TELL YA,
CONGRATULATIONS
ON GETTING THE NEW JOB.
- OH, THANKS, MAN.
I APPRECIATE IT.
- AWESOME, THAT'S AWESOME.
- YEAH, AND THANK YOU
FOR INVITING ME OVER HERE
TO THE GAME TODAY.
- OH, NO PROBLEM.
I MEAN,
YOU'RE MY BEST FRIEND.
- WOW, THANKS, MAN.
HEY, YOU KNOW WHAT?
YOU'RE MY BEST FRIEND TOO.
- COOL.
- YEAH, YEAH, YEAH.
- WROTE A SONG ABOUT IT.
- [laughs]
- NOT GONNA SING IT OR ANYTHING,
'CAUSE THAT WOULD BE GAY.
- [laughing]
THAT'S PRETTY GAY.
- ALL RIGHT,
I'LL GIVE IT A SHOT.
[clears throat]
♪ WALLY,
YOU'RE MY BEST FRIEND ♪
♪ TOGETHER WE CAN
CHANGE THE WORLD ♪
♪ WE'VE BEEN TOGETHER
THROUGH THICK AND THIN ♪
♪ PLAYING BALL
AND TALKING TO GIRLS ♪
♪ WALLY,
I'M SO PROUD OF YOU ♪
♪ YOU KNOW YOU'VE TAKEN
ALL OF MY ADVICE ♪
- WAIT, STOP, STOP, STOP,
STOP...WHAT ADVICE?
- OH, UM...
IT'S JUST A SONG, DUDE.
I MEAN, LIKE,
CAN I FINISH?
- YEP.
- AND THEN WE CAN?
- O-OKAY.
- ALL RIGHT.
[clears throat]
♪ YOU'VE DONE EVERYTHING
I'VE ASKED OF YOU ♪
♪ AND YOU NEVER,
EVER QUESTIONED TWICE ♪
- WHAT ARE YOU
TALKING ABOUT?
♪ THANK YOU FOR DOING
WHAT I TOLD YOU TO ♪
♪ YOUR ACHIEVEMENTS
ARE ALSO MINE ♪
♪ MY PADAWAN ♪
♪ YOU MAKE
YOUR SENSEI PROUD ♪
♪ LIVING YOUR LIFE
LIVING YOUR LIFE ♪
[low]
TWO, THREE, FOUR...
♪ LIVING YOUR LIFE
TO MY DESIGN ♪
- THAT WAS THE WEIRDEST SONG
I'VE EVER HEARD IN MY LIFE, SO--
- ♪ YOU HAVE LISTENED
TO YOUR ELDERS ♪
- I'M OLDER THAN YOU!
- ♪ NEVER FORGET ♪
♪ THE WORDS I SAY ♪
- OKAY, I, UH,
DON'T LIKE YOUR SONG,
SO I'M GONNA BOUNCE.
- ♪ YOU ARE PRODUCT
OF MY CREATION ♪
- WHAT? NO I'M NOT.
- ♪ I HAVE SHOWN YOU THE WAY ♪
- EXCEPT FOR THAT YOU HAVEN'T.
YOU HAVEN'T.
- ♪ MODULATE ♪
- YOU JUST SAY
WHAT YOU'RE DOING?
- ♪ LIKE THE WHITE WOLF
GUIDES HIS CUBS ♪
♪ THROUGH THE PLAINS
OF THE CARIBOU ♪
- SHUT UP!
- ♪ I HAVE DONE
ALL I CAN ♪
♪ THE REST IS UP TO ♪
[high]
♪ YOU ♪
MY WOLF CUB
IS ALL GROWN UP.
[shudders]